is this a vote no i want to hear like
can you work with him i'm gonna give him
a chance but i am
very hesitant on it i will say
becky would you be willing to work with
him
i am willing to work with him but he's
not going to take over what i do
charlie will you work with him last time
i saw this guy
maldova we found out he's a criminal
then this guy tries to hit me
and now i'm supposed to just welcome him
with open arms to the family business
nah
he needs to come basically kiss our ass
and say i'm sorry for being that's
the bottom line not if he's being
catered to
okay he needs to bust his ass would you
be willing to show him the ropes
and teach him the business for your
sister i got one thing to say
okay
what all right i'm moving and i'm
leaving what
charlie if he wants to do this earn
it earn it that's not why we're here
that's all i'm saying i'm gonna sit here
and
listen to this we just had a meeting
about your husband the whole time
all we did was sit here and talk about
your husband you're not gonna say
him
[Music]
wow i'm just feeling like
really defeated because my husband is
trying and i know that he's trying
and everyone is saying like he needs to
do this he needs to do that
but he's just trying to do what is best
for his family and to make money what's
so
wrong with that